you
well thanks 12s for being here today
it's uh it's it's great to see you to be
here again it's great to have you come
in and and share your thoughts with us
at the Microsoft Research AI
Distinguished Lecture series we've known
each other for a very long time I
remember when I think when you are a
grad student asking all these questions
that informs that the the the the
international meeting of operations
research and management science I turned
around I said this really smart guy
asking all these questions and I first
met Thomas that way and and what I what
I really was excited about was it seemed
we shared interests in our persons
research decision analysis ai the span
the arc of concepts to all those fields
which only more recently have come
together in for the current view point
on and perspective on machine
intelligence and so that would that was
tie bliss how did you get going in this
whole area except I knew you had a
history Nokia you know being in Finland
and working as a young student in areas
around probability and statistics how
did you get into this field yeah I
actually started studying management
science and industrial engineering and
and then just operations research and
systems analysis and AI really just drew
me in as a undergrad really and then for
master's thesis I built the track on it
which is the first distributed system
for negotiation among self-interested
agents and that really spawned more
questions than answers so I decided to
come to the US do my PhD in that and
it's always been kind of
interdisciplinary between computer
science and an area in particular and
operations research and economics in
particular game theory yeah so go back
to that project Ian what was the cause
again and record net or transportation
cooperation net what was it all about it
was a this thing where I got to really
shape it myself as a master's thesis
student they have solved this project in
Finland at the Technical Research Center
of Finland and they have solved this
project before I joined to some
companies there some trucking needs some
of them were transporting heavy goods
like
destruction things and others were
transporting very light things and so on
and then they realized that they had
some potential for cooperation
reallocating tasks among themselves and
so on and that from there I could just
take it in any direction I wanted and I
wanted to build and automated
negotiations well I had like three
different options to look at master's
thesis and I liked that as the most
open-ended you know what were these
practical projects you get to engage in
yeah there's a master's thesis or
master's research thesis and yeah and
there were many different options and I
like three of them and this I like the
best it's also what got you excited
about the self interest in distributed
aspects of things but I've been studying
a game theory and optimization and I
felt that a lot of the stuff hadn't been
put together so there's a lot of good
work on integer programming and things
like that and a lot of good work in game
theory people hadn't really put those
two things together and did this
tracking system work out yeah yeah so it
was just a prototype system so way we
collected real data and showed how it
would work on real data but it wasn't
ever and we didn't actually field it or
anything that was deemed the goal which
was really just a prototype and and
they're not left to the u.s. to do my
PhD okay before we get to the PhD work
beyond let's take a brief break and talk
about your wind surfing career so how
did that get going and had to become
like the Finland champ in Windsor yeah
so I've been racing sailboats since I
was a little kid and then you can really
sail optimistic news until you 15 but I
got too big and heavy so the boat
wouldn't just go and and I saw so I
needed a different class and windsurfing
had just become so hot hot and athletic
and it could actually take a little bit
to a bigger guy so I started windsurfing
and then in a couple of years some of
the coaches in Finland it kind of saw
saw me and how I did in the races and
they picked me on the national team for
four and a half years so throughout high
school and throughout the Air Force I
was actually sailing around in the World
Championships and and so when I'm
windsurfing and in the winters we would
go down south to practice when five
was all covered with ice software Canary
Islands sound state was a finished
person go to fact the state
yeah always was impressed I think you
mentioned this in the past and I even
senior formal CV you know yes I City six
of those well you know Finland
windsurfing champ yes yes and my best
race was actually being the fifth in the
Europeans I was also 12 in the worlds
but really the best races were mean to
Europeans before we get off that you
still do it sir yeah even though it's
not hot anymore no it's it's actually
really nice that it's not hot anymore
you have a lot more space to do it that
should be a pile boys by this time no no
so I'm kind of loyal to what I do yeah
and never ice hockey I I played ice
hockey as a kid okay just being a
Finnish kid you don't have to just
checking out of this I know you play so
that's then you went off to to Amherst
yeah and how was that experience and
what kind of things just work on there
great yeah I had read a lot of papers
and Maltese and systems already doing
this transportation cooperation net
system in Finland and I looked at who's
publishing most in multi-agent systems
and st. Victor Lester email and he
accepted me as a grad student we
actually flew there to meet before we
committed so we kind of interviewed each
other a little bit them and then we
decided to work together right it was
great I was found Viktor with many years
a very very kind thoughtful caring man
that's right we still talk about that
Stephanie he's still my vein mentor it's
fabulous and I'm sure he probably some
of his personality has mentorship
abilities that rubbed off on you over
the years
yeah I try and so and so he finished
that up and then what was next for you
you're 50 yeah so then I went to be a
assistant professor at Washington
University st. Louis where I started my
own research group and and then four
years later
CMU hired me out of there and and so it
seemed a business this is force in
in in combinatorial options and some
interesting results you've proved in and
your students have proved in that space
over the years and you've not only done
this great scholarship you've been
spinning out companies like combine it
and I think you were wondering combine
that for many years I must be at least a
decade yes I yeah so combine it
I built this started building the
technology in 97 and then I founded the
company in 2000 and you're right I mean
we were continuing until 2010 before it
was acquired and we fielded 800 of the
world still largest scale combinatorial
auctions ever fielded totaling 60
billion dollars and we created a supply
chain efficiency of over 6 billion
dollars so it doesn't of course they
gave you most of that money right a
sourcing software is the worst business
I can tell you that in terms of row
margins hopefully a little piece of it
at some point yeah you have to you have
to basically sell software to the
toughest negotiations in the negotiators
in the world that's what they do all day
long they push the suppliers down on
pricing so they do the same to the
software vendors so what's your
experience like with that whole the
whole startup yeah it was very
interesting you know a lot of people
think that the interaction between
academia and startup kids like you you
just license technology from academia
and it's a one-way but this was really
both ways actually more so the other way
where we actually saw problems in the
real world that hadn't been looked at in
academia and many of those things we
actually brought back to my academic lab
and then we were the first ones to look
at these things like preference
solicitation in multigon systems
automated mechanism design structured
domain-specific bidding languages for
combinatorial auctions etc etc so so
what did you
when did you start getting involved in
going from that that room and I see the
relationships but some people in the
outside world might not see them to the
world the realm of kidney exchanges it
how'd you get exposed to it maybe you
can explain to folks some of the things
that with it with the big grand
challenge of kidney exchanges is and why
it's a hard problem why it's so valuable
to solve and then how you got interested
in that does it really multi-part
question okay great so how I got
interested in kidneys what is it first
what is this all about this okay so
kidney exchange is there to help
alleviate the problems there aren't
enough organ donors who donate organs
when they die
so there's this big imbalance of supply
and demand and not just in the US but in
most countries so for example in the
u.s. there are over a hundred thousand
people that are listed to wait for dead
people's kidneys and these are people
who are very sick and are eventually
going to die if they don't get them so
you can do live donation because most
people have two kidneys like if you get
sick I can give you one of my kidneys I
offer to give you one but chances are I
can't do two blood type and tissue type
incompatibility and a few other factors
so that's where kidney exchange comes in
so you actually at the simplest to swap
the donors so if we were willing pair
donor patient pair some other pair is
willing but also incompatible it'll be
anywhere in the world it could well
currently they're just within countries
but many countries have them but so
think about in the u.s. California
Massachusetts say so I'm gonna donate to
somebody else and their donor is gonna
donate to you now both of the patients
can live if you think about that from a
graph perspective that's a two-cycle you
can also do 3 cycles and you can do what
we call never-ending outreach donor
initiated chains so somebody actually
gives a kidney doesn't expect anything
in return instead of a cycle that
triggers a chain in the network and at
the end of the chain there's the last
willing donor which can served as this
as this altruist in the next week's
optimization patch and it's a gift that
keeps giving but the hard optimization
problem in the bat setting is figuring
out the optimal combination of cycles
and shakes okay so that's the challenge
how on earth did you first get exposed
to this and get excited about it so I
was on the organization committee of the
International Congress of the game
theory Society in 2004 and as one of our
invited speakers we invited al Roth who
had just started working with medical
collaborators and some other economists
on the New England paired kidney
exchange and he spoke about kidney
exchange so that's how I first heard
about it and I saw that there were a lot
of kind of computer science the worries
problems in there and I thought okay
that would be a nice way to do some pro
bono work and to give back and give back
yeah exactly so this is not a startup we
run the nationwide kidney exchange for
eunice so we donate the software from my
CMU lattice Eunice oh you know squid
Eunice is the United Network for Organ
Sharing they control the transplantation
in the US and both on the deceased donor
side and kidney exchange side at least
for the National kidney exchange and our
software runs the kidney exchange side
of it so every week it makes a
transplant plan for 69 percent of the
transplant centers amazing in the US and
this is all we got we're giving away the
software it's not a start-up and do you
well first of all before I even get into
how it works and how you monitor it and
so on what hard core problems even if
they're just applications in and
transfer of existing ideas did you have
to sort of work with to solve the the
kidney exchange challenge so one was
this just this optimization problem and
the batch optimization problem but then
as we got more into it we realized that
that's not the only thing there are a
lot of things that go around so for
example the problem is dynamic patients
die they get diseased donor organs other
kidney exchanges may snipe them you know
other things might happen they get sick
they can't be transplanted so the
problem is dynamic and also new pairs
come to the exchange new arteries come
to the exchange and so on another issue
is that there are what I call
pre-transplant phase
years so the medical knowledge is
incomplete if it says that we're
compatible in reality I may or may not
be and turns out that most kidney
exchange structures cycles or chains
worldwide actually failed before
transplant because if even one of those
edges turns out to be actually not
compatible or one of the patients dies
or gets a deceased donor organ something
happens between the planning stage and
the operation which is about eight weeks
typically the whole structure fails 90%
of the structures fail so how can we
actually do this failure we're planning
we just had a paper out in management
science on that and you can get much
better numbers of transplants by not
just looking at how good an edge would
be a good transfer good it would be but
how likely it is to succeed as well so
now you're taking extra information into
account and you're making these more
robust plans where's the likely to come
from the likelihood seating I mean if
the likelihood of succeeding could come
from machine learning models but even if
you just say that it's the same average
probability across everybody you get
still a hundred to 150 percent lift in
transplants so even if you don't take
into account the fact that some ages are
more likely to fail than others and what
this looks like then in practice you
have shorter cycles you have shorter
chains and more parallelism in the plans
so where so then those structures are
less likely to fail because they have
fewer edges and if they do fail it
affects fewer tragedies and is it the
case that patient and nephrologist and
team and family will ever have to do a
notion this idea of trade like mmm my
kidney function is crashing at this rate
or I can't do more dialysis it's hard to
wait longer but this match is not great
to wait for the next to match and have a
probability distribution over the
problem of getting a better match with
an
time horizon tea yes some people look at
that as as a decision as to how long
should you wait we haven't really
studied that so much and it's my
understanding at you know patients
really aren't presented a menu of
kidneys or anything like that it's more
like wearing a matching kidneys found
people are very happy with it
no I'll tell you what one a little bit
of a counter example to what I just said
we were we were working with the
Alliance for paired donation this was in
2006-2007 it's a it's a private kidney
exchange and there they were seized I'm
gonna say 60-year old uncle and a 13
year old kid a 13 year old girl and it
was clear that that 60 year old kidney
would not last adequately long in that
little kid because the little kids still
had a lot of life ahead of her this
thing is look at the actual amount of
trade you have any okie receive into it
into a patient instead is there for the
future
so what they could have they were
actually compatible already without the
kidney exchange but they came to the
kidney exchange and say that you're you
know you have three months if you can
find a better match for the girl the
uncle is going to give to somebody else
and we actually algorithmically found a
better match just in the normal process
so now we took this compatible pair put
them into the kidney exchange and for
somebody who was older that uncle's
kidney was great yeah and then the girl
cut ahead and I thought about in organ
transplants that you have the age of the
tissue itself and SBS you know this both
will these cells live as long as this
patient perform yes time when they have
their own lifespan as part of the the
donors life history yes interesting so
moving on from the medical successes in
other areas so you see your team is
renowned for beating the best players
that heads up No Limit Texas Hold'em
poker and this is
remarkable in some ways in that it goes
beyond what we often refer to as the
simplicity frankly of games of perfect
information you can explain the
difference that you know going from
checkers or go into the realm of
uncertainty bluffing yeah human
dimension yeah so imperfect information
games like let's say tic-tac-toe
checkers chess go you know exactly what
the state of the world is when it's your
turn to move and then you can use
techniques like minimax search alpha
beta pruning and in game databases that
that poor stuff you can build huge
databases by just playing oneself a
trillion times yes well yes and they
have been great successes some of those
games are very difficult as well like
chess is still unsolved go is still
unsolved but they have reached
superhuman level at that and it's very
impressive in imperfect information
games The Situation's totally different
none of those algorithms applied in
imperfect information games you don't
know the state of the world when it's
your turn to act and to complicate
things your opponents may know things
that you don't know and vice-versa
so you have to think about what do my
actions signal to the opponent about my
private information and I have to think
about what to my opponent's action
signal to me about their private
information and it is balancing act and
the history of the evidential stream as
well exactly well absolutely yeah you
have to think about the history of the
actions because that's where the beliefs
get updated from so you would think
about it as a generalization of pom DPS
but into the game setting and yeah so
it's much more difficult you have to
think about those beliefs and then you
need to go to game theoretic reasoning
so it's actually interesting that how
you should up update the beliefs falls
out of the classic game theoretic
solution concepts like Nash equilibrium
and it's refinements but the works
really about how do you marry those
solution concepts with algorithms from
AI so we can
actually compute good approximations of
Nash equilibrium and its refinements
okay so people have been trying to solve
this problem for decades you know what
was the magic or the unique innovation
is that your team came up with that I
guess I have to say it wasn't in one
cycle you've been you've been doing this
for a while that's right and you finally
got the win but what what's what's some
of the the findings and results okay so
there have been a lot so I've been
working on poker as one of the
benchmarks since 2004 so from 2004 to
2007 teen 13 years so it wasn't like one
night we came up with something and it
was done it was just like accumulation
of ideas this is the same time span we
have Thomas thinking about exchanges and
take a break poker yeah but that that's
maybe yes that's kind of a my style of
research at combinatorial auctions where
you're 10 15 years kidney exchange was
10-15 years and still is and
combinatorial auctions too but it takes
a while to really learn the problem and
learn the techniques at work so it's not
like one paper and that's brilliant
themselves the whole thing it doesn't
work like that
yeah so one is abstraction techniques
how do you automatically abstract the
game into a smaller game so when you
solve the smaller game perhaps even not
only approximately the results are good
answers the strategies are good
strategies for the original game the
second is the equilibrium finding
algorithms so how do you actually take a
game and find exact or near optimal
strategies for that game in a
computationally efficient way both for
memory and for speed and there I would
say the number one thing that actually
got us over the finish line at the very
end clearly there was accumulation of
work up to it up to then but the last
thing was these sub game solving
techniques safe new sub game solving
techniques that really got the final
jump 63 million per game Champa say more
about that well what goes on
yeah so normally if you wouldn't mean by
sublimity yeah so if you normally think
about perfect information games you
could think about let's say I talk about
chess so you get to a state and when
then you start thinking about what do
you do from there you think from there
to the end of the game or to some
virtual end of the game if you will
this is easy relatively speaking in
imperfect information games because you
can solve the game theoretic solution
for a sub game based on information only
in that sub game in imperfect
information games you can't because you
have to think about the balance of
strategies across multiple imperfect
information game sub games so as to not
give out too much information for your
opponent and what these sub game solving
techniques to is that they take this
idea of sub game solving into imperfect
information games which is very
different than imperfect information
games and the techniques actually look
totally different but still we can find
provably optimal sub game solving
techniques so we don't have to look at
the whole game at once and therefore in
the sub games we can actually solve much
finer grained abstractions come up with
much better strategies then you can
afford to computationally do if you try
to solve the whole game monolithically
let me ask you something if do you see
how hard it was to solve some of these
problems and to get to the level of that
could be the human or a set of top-notch
humans in this in this space
how on earth do you means do such a good
job at this that is so amazing that's a
great question
so these humans they just are I can't
even describe it they're just so good at
this game which is so hard and they can
talk about these detailed things some of
them don't even have college degrees
many of them actually do and some of
them computer science and economics and
so on University correlated with their
skill set but they can talk about these
concepts
that they've really learned in this game
specific way which is which is very
interesting and they also have amazing
memories about the game so one guy was
one of these players will just finish
the match he had played thirty thousand
hands personally against this AI and
taper again thirty thousand hands of
poker against brothers yeah
so overall the four players played a
hundred and twenty thousand hands so we
get statistical significance and to give
the humans the best chance to find holes
in the AI so you want to play a lot of
hands twenty days
so eighty days total of work twenty days
yeah so she was asked you know can you
come up with an example where the AI
exhibited this type of behavior and he
would recall that hand out of a thirty
thousand just like that that's amazing
so so I mean I'm amazed at what you know
like can do us sitting here being
immersed situated in the situation
understanding each other language
abilities but when you take a
constrained games there's complexity
like that and this is the human beings
become specialists they just do create
at this they have memory that indexes
into what happened you know strategy it
really is impressive very impressive on
the other hand you know they do nothing
but these all day long special speaking
of that topic
what about and I'm sure the goal was not
nothing this I just beat the best
players at poker it was about two
understands we've seen intelligence
better so what have you learned about AI
in the process of working with
librettists and where it went for
generalizable principles and other kinds
of problems you might solve in the world
in the open world yeah that's a great
question so one is that these techniques
are not techniques for poker
therefore imperfect information games in
general and as a think about it most
real-world situations are imperfect
information games even if they're not
treated as games today even example make
it clear pricing so typically people
when the companies when they optimize
they treat it as an optimization problem
assuming the competitors prices are
fixed and then when the competitors
changed prices then Yuri optimized
you're always kind of in a reactive mode
behind the 8-ball while if you think
about these pricing moves ahead you can
actually do what I call strategic
pricing and this this kind of thing
happens in a lot of industries finance
investment banking sports video games
and and so on so this has a lot of
applications and I'm actually so excited
a type of founded two companies to fill
this one is called strategic machine and
then for government application strategy
robots
we're taking these techniques that we've
developed in the lab over 16 years now
and yeah fielding them into a bunch of
things so one is that I think you do
need to think about imperfect
information you do need to deal with
opponents trying to deceive you and so
on so that's one the other is kind of
there's a lot of talk about oversight of
AI and we got into this point and I
don't think it's just us I think as a
community as well where whenever human
players top players even would say no
that's a mistake
I would actually know that chances are
that the human is wrong not the AI so
you know you're human oversight question
really became which application is
actually poker I'm talking about poker
so they're even the best poker players
when they would say it ok that was a
mistake you mean oh you mean a poor move
poor move yeah or a poor strategy
sometimes you can't think about the
moves in isolation you have to think
about all stretchy so if they have a
ghost story we saw so we saw examples
hmm that's a poor move and they turned
out to be unique interesting yes yes
so some kind of move sometimes these
super human moves or strategies are not
really easily valuable by humans so when
you must say that's a mistake
maybe not and I think that's something
that as we want to get humans to be
augmented by AI we need to think about
how do we deal with
fact that humans can't really provide
proper oversight for aí and aí may also
have its own weaknesses in providing
oversight to humans so there should be
this kind of mutual oversight but how do
you do that's really when the humans
can't evaluate superhuman moves so so
where are you you're taking on
directions there feel free to speculate
in real time okay well um I actually
don't really think that humans can
provide very good oversight for AI in
the long run because they don't
understand super human moves and so
that's one and other is that for a while
as you get superhuman moves you can give
humans extra data around that decision
and give them time to understand them
and evaluate them and try to understand
why wasn't it good why was it bad and so
on we actually did this Chris Ferguson
was looking at their moves sometimes
offline where something looked like a
really bad move to me or to one of the
top poker players and we would actually
isolate it and we were so okay
at that point here were the belief
distributions of the AI here's the
belief distributions that they would
have had if it were in the human shoes
and from these belief distributions was
that the good play and with three days
of analysis and oftentimes a little
essay to go with it Chris was able said
actually that looked like a dumb move
but it actually is like thinking two
levels deeper than humans ever do and
it's actually a brilliant move so with
some hindsight and time and extra
context
he must actually are able to appreciate
and evaluate superhuman moves but I
think that'll go away that'll only go
for a while when the superhuman moves
aren't too superhuman yet but once you
get beyond a certain point I don't think
so some moves
advertised a superhuman might be
erroneous might be actually wrong that's
right and so people get used to
accepting moves they don't understand
the opacity there it's unclear what the
policy should be about humans actually
providing some oversight and yes stop
things or shunt them or modify them yeah
yeah and there's also if you think about
things like robots you know where you
have to do in real time you know did you
take over the controls or don't you and
you say I might have driven you into a
situation where it can still recover but
the human can't because the human
doesn't go into those state space parts
and so on so it's a very complicated to
watch us we have validation and some
notion of trust it might turn out that
we have to give robotic systems
automated systems the ability to
download so that doing things that are
understandable to human beings so they
can be yeah understood and and and
guided if necessary yeah which might be
a gentle trade between
optimality and winning a game for
example and just doing a great job yeah
I do think yeah this bus and some
applications might be a gentle trade
like hey are you gonna take over the
wheel in the car yeah that's probably a
gentle trade so but in other
applications I think the trade of won't
be that gentle and and we may have to
give up in some applications we better
understand the be certainly you might
not win a poker game if this moves yeah
interesting so tell me a little bit
about strategy robot and and why this
interest in helping governments with
their projects well it's actually I
started it with a strategic machine
first which was really for everything
and anything out that the the potential
customer bases are totally different and
other requirements are different so
actually had to split it into one for
the commercial side strategic machine
and then one for the government things
which is strategy robot telling where
the government work what kinds of
problems are you solving there so far
we're targeting things like military
planning cyber security applications
intelligence wargaming training things
like that very interesting the whole
area of AI you've been in for many years
and it's fabulous
we're both involved in the in this
wonderful long-term mission to
understand intelligence there are
different perspectives different
approaches different methodologies but
certainly a big difference in point of
perspective is people who work on kind
of central algorithms and deeply
coordinated approaches and kind of the
people that often rely on the power of
distributed distribution methods
theorems equilibria seeking intelligence
in a system as as the sum of many many
parts that are interacting certain
properties I'm curious where you are
these days and you're thinking about you
at the foundations of human intelligence
the importance of central coordination
versus distributed processing ok that's
a that's a big question ask little
questions like ok so I started out by
thinking at you know part of the reason
for distribution is autonomy and part of
its computational efficiency and those
are kind of the distributions the same
for the tool and in in the tracker net
system that's an example where we did
distributed negotiation peer-to-peer
totally distributed but then when I
moved to combinatorial options around 97
it became clear that you can actually
get better allocations and more
efficiently by having a centralized
clearing point like an auction server
combinatorial auction server with
centralized optimization algorithms
doing the allocation so then there was
this autonomy notion of different
bidders but it wasn't from a
computational perspective from a
computational perspective it was
actually better to centralized and now
if you think about how the that works
for example with a we built our own
hosting service we were a software as a
service company one of the first
analytics software service companies but
today it would be cloud and is at
optimize markets which is you know
combinatorial mark
company that I'm running there the
distribution kind of that autonomy based
distribution self-interest based
distribution is totally different than
the computational distribution in that
from the player's perspective it's a
centralized marketplace while from a
computational perspective the clearing
engine or the marketplace driving
optimization that is distributed in the
cloud across multiple servers but those
are all in the centralized clearing
point so the distribution for autonomy
and the distribution for computational
speed they're totally different
they're both in the same market at the
same time but they're different sorry so
there's no summary answer why do you
think that you have to have just
intellect on both kinds of processes
coordination might always be necessary
at some level more centralized I want to
say it's always necessary but especially
when it comes to these combinatorial
problems getting good solutions or let's
say optimal solutions or near optimal
solutions in this combinatorial
allocation problems it is very hard to
do in a peer-to-peer way without a
centralized clearing point so maybe it's
just my experience
TRUCKING being the least sexy but most
combinatorial problem ever you know that
may be kind of driving my thinking of
that but just we saw the more
combinatorics there are the more benefit
there is to a centralized clearing point
you know your experience I don't usually
ask this question of folks but I thought
I'd get you to speculate in real time
what do you think's going on in the
human mind whatwhat what's your favorite
well intuitions about what might be
going on that performs all this magic oh
I kind of made a commit fairly early on
not to worry about it too much as they
worry I said what's your invested you
must have some guesses and some
inspiration some thoughts insights even
if they're even if we know they're just
guesses right now because sometimes
these guesses guide our research even
though we don't talk about this very
much hmm I mean maybe less so I actually
when I was picking a research topic in
the eighties one of the other areas I
was very
Christina had done some things was deep
learning and I guess I mean like
connectionism in those days yeah neural
networks and and I was very interesting
in that then and just kind of by half
fate you know this is more the game
theory strand is more kind of where I
went and for better or worse it's been
an interesting ride but I kind of don't
know so much about what's going in the
human mind but you but it sounds like
that was an early curiosity of yours
yes very even have powered up the whole
AI direction yes very much keep it that
right now okay we won't speculate
especially on video okay turning to
other people and you've been a great
mentor to many students over the years
and you've had a very successful career
and much more to come
what are some words of wisdom you'd like
to share with with young folks about
career more generally even inside or
outside of computer science ah okay
interesting now you probably will never
on in video or anywhere else if we asked
those two different questions side by
side words and thoughts are there in
computer science but my advice would be
at there make sure you have some
real-world problem at your work because
it will whew well a lot of interesting
research questions into the research
agenda and it's very hard to come up
with those questions that are
significant if you're just sitting in
your office with your feet on the table
trying to flip through proceedings so
it's better to be the person who
publishes the first article on some
topic and brings a new order a new
question into the field rather than
being the guy who flips through approach
proceedings looking for potential
improvements that's my opinion we've
done some of the latter too but I think
that's been less impactful in
Interdisciplinary so I found as being
great to be able to draw knowledge from
multiple different fields so one example
is the game theory and optimization
intersection another is really the
intersection between AI techniques and
integer programming techniques
these fields didn't really talk to each
other much and this was tremendously
helpful and now they talk talk - it's
another much more but it was really
great to actually know the techniques
from both sides and being able to
contribute to that intersection with
both types of tools it's in hand and so
just reading on both sides reading
broadly and not drawing boundaries I
instead of thinking about hey in a paper
or sometimes see people write computer
scientists think these economists think
that or things like that I would never
mention a field of science in a paper
and I encourage that nobody else does
either because that erect boundaries
between fields instead of taking them
down it doesn't really matter whether it
was an economist or a computer scientist
or an o'er person who said this or that
that's really irrelevant and a waste of
space in a paper fabulous well with that
thanks very much it's been great talk
thank you